magnus said there's no meaning to life
do you guys agree
or no why are we here
i do not know why we're here
but i do know that
having some kind of meaning that i give
my own life
makes it
a lot more motivating every day so i
just try to focus on finding meaning
within my own life even if i know it's
just self-imposed
and then chess is a part of that
chess
is a part of it
maybe it was more so
when i was younger because it was easier
to just feel like i want to improve as a
person
and
to use chess to kind of measure some
kind of self-improvement
and now it's
more different than that and i think i
need to once again find what that you
know
northern star is basically i need to
have a why for why i'm doing things and
then i feel like i could do very hard
things
what uh role does love play in the human
condition
alex and andrea i'll let andrea start
this one since i took the last sure
and yeah just to add my answer for the
last one i
also
kind of think well life is meaningless
but i like the stoic idea where that's
something that you live to revolt
against
but for the second question
i have the revolt against the
fundamental meaninglessness of life
exactly
yeah
it was what does love play what role
does love play yeah in the human
condition
the way i see it i
love is a reason you want to share
experiences with other people
that's how i see it like the people you
really love you want to share the things
you're going through with them
um the good and the bad yeah exactly
that's my simple take on love
my take on it is that
part of what it is to be human is to be
somebody who
feels things emotionally and love
is one of the most intense feelings you
can have
um obviously there's the opposite of
that and there's things like hate but i
think the love you feel for people like
your parents and your friends and
romantic love in that moment is much
more
intense than in other situations
um and i think it's also just very
unique to humans and that's
what i appreciate about it maybe that's
the meaning of life
maybe that's what the stoics are
searching for
uh andrea alex thank you so much for
this and thank you for an amazing
conversation thank you for creating keep
creating and thank you for putting
knowledge and love out there in the
world
thank you for having us
it was a pleasure and uh we're both big
fans of your podcast so this was really
exciting for us
you